pour tous avec de ramallah
à vélo ou à pied c'est patrouilleurs de
la brigade des espaces publics du
service de police de la ville de
montréal préparent leur itinéraire leur
mandat sillonné les rues du centre-ville
et intervenir en matière d'incivilités
et de vente de stupéfiants les policiers
vont sur le terrain à la rencontre de
gens qui présentent quand même une
certaine vulnérabilité donc des gens en
situation d'itinérance en crise ou dont
l'état mental est perturbé et leur
réponse devient un peu plus humaine une
bonne initiative selon ce militant qui
défend les droits des sans abri et qui
affirme que des problèmes liés aux
interventions de cette brigade persiste
depuis sa création il y a quatre ans il
espère un réel changement de cap
trop souvent c'est qu'ils avaient des
interventions qui étaient parfois
abusive du bris de matériel de
consommation de la saisie du matériel de
vidage de canettes de bière et
contraventions qui sont remises alors
que les gens sont sans abri c'est pour
la solution
au centre-ville de montréal cette équipe
de la brigade des espaces publics
intervient auprès de squatters dans ce
terrain vague qui deviendra bientôt un
chantier de construction en férié avec
des réseaux communautaires qui vont mais
les rencontres et qui vont commencer à
établir un pont avec ces gens là pour
éventuellement les conscientiser au fait
la voie de la construction qui vont
devoir se déplacer dans un autre endroit
le spvm assure que donner des
contraventions et procédé à des
arrestations sont désormais les derniers
recours pour cette équipe de policiers
mais pour ceux sans abri les policiers
devraient parfois se montrer plus
compréhensif et plus tolérant gsm et
bien ce gsm et place de skate basques
des timbres sont métro et 15 chalon me
débarque d'un point
des juments âgées de ce qu'elles savent
de shibuya pas béni si complètement
comble pas inutile
selon certains intervenants il faudrait
plus de formation et une meilleure
collaboration avec des organismes qui
viennent en aide aux personnes les plus
démunies
enfin surtout aux nouvelles recrues qui
ont très peu d'expérience c'est vraiment
le bon moment pour les former mais faut
que la formation soit continu il est
difficile pour l'instant de dresser un
bilan des premiers mois d'action de
cette nouvelle équipe mais de façon
générale cette initiative du spvm semble
bien accueillie par les sans abri et par
les organismes qui les aide ici florence
guaino radio canada montréal